hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to unforgiving northern
him now I found out what these posters
are all about there's an option in the
main menu called collected stories and
each of these has a poem depicting one
of the ancient stories of I imagine
Swedish floor so there's the various
things like what we're seeing now and
they're collected all through the
different chapters of the game and
actually I think the most recent one I
found was this one which means that
we're in chapter 7 of a game of only
nine chapters we may finish this game in
this next chapter if I am diligent
enough and don't die a million times
over to stupid things that are
completely preventable but I'm doing my
infinite ignorance I'm unable to defeat
but anyway so I don't think we can turn
this on right now oh yes we can
ah how inspirational are these cans of
gasoline oh good that one was empty full
empty empty oh good I'm finding the
right one with which to do something
terrible no I found a winner
I found a winner okay alright the fall
of the false god the false god saw how
lovely freya was and fell for her beauty
he made plans to play as violent for her
charming her with his music however
freya saw right through his ruse okay
alright well it was a pretty nice ruse
yeah nobody would have fallen for that
when they speak to you outside trying to
get you to give him a harp of some sort
alright was it up that one or was it up
this one I think it was a decision
wasn't it up here storage oh hello oh
yeah no I think that was definitely it
okay well everybody hold on to your hats
boy you may not I
and most of fitness oh oh geez oh geez
oh god oh maybe I couldn't just like
hacked off an arm I don't want to do it
I don't there's no other way well aren't
I so happy with myself yeah that
trickster God doesn't want to mess with
me I'm crazy oh god that's so horrible
why does the game make you do that
where'd that tree lady have to try to
keep her child safe right there man do
you think I'm the only one that's ever
done that like there's been there's been
so many options for people to try to go
into storage and they've been like now
you know what I'm not gonna do that
horrible thing that is obviously not
even remotely a choice in my mind
because I'm not insane and I wouldn't do
that but I come along and nope oh my
first didn't think this to burn down
everything dive deepest into depravity
like I've already thorned my brothers
tongue and eyeball out without even
being prompted to that was just
something that I did and then was like
oh my god oh god I just instantly dive
into the worst scenario possible no
question no hesitation just right into
it oh my god hello how's it going
there anybody want to tell me anything
about what's happening you gonna slap me
okay okay nobody slapped me I'm already
slapped all right into the water
hey hey hey hey hey hey doll this this
is what I hate this thing that I'm in
right now I hate hate every bit of it
hey hey hey hey hey oh who dropped a
turd oh hey hey hey
oh hi okay I guess they've gone back at
the water then I'm dead I'm dead I'm
dead you can swim too oh that's not good
okay well okay what are you doing what
are you doing
[Music]
please tell me that you're just gonna
dive headfirst into that pool of light
good great you looking good good good
good good good good good good good good
good good good good ok here we go all
right putting this log with me this game
is awesome and I love it why are we
screaming now wise now ok why is not the
time to scream I ask myself
at frequent times ok all right whatever
you say wherever we're gonna go in here
I'm sure it's gonna be wonderful and
delightful
Oh Who am I gonna burn down exile good
storage good I'm glad that storage
wasn't held that anywhere near the
actual doorway into storage whose it was
deep in a pit filled with water and muck
and horrible monsters that's where I
want to keep all my valuables oh this is
not a fun picture that's the worst
picture okay all right anyway hidden
worlds - they are a theory said among
the worlds of Hebrew the live about word
there exists an underworld the purgatory
a place where humans have to competent
late prior choices in atone for their
sins door with the spikes on the top
right there that's a good one huh
why did I come in here that's still the
question that I have I did I need to
come in here I didn't I don't know if I
need anything we got hungry they ate the
dog great okay yeah yeah I can see that
we got hungry I miss Bobbye oh man oh
man Oh the game just meant to make me
feel terrible
hunting flying and cutting up living off
the poor I get it instructions on how to
survive in the world I get it they ain't
the dog I'm so sad now I am so sad
there's Joe's ad what is this I got I
came all this way for that for a plug
you know what it's great that's what I
expected to happen after all this that's
what I was anticipating everything about
this is led up to that moment yeah that
makes sense to me of which that is that
thing that happened to me
why don't you dare I will I will slap
the [ __ ] out of you okay yeah you carry
out on your stupid little loop your
piece of Garbo I will smack the piss out
of you I will send you into yesteryear
mister that's right you better keep
walking [ __ ] yeah okay alright okay
yeah oh what's that oh oh yeah walk away
from your problems oh yeah you suck the
ink I do nothing bout it my titty
sprinkles come on you want to fight I'm
right here right here come on that's
right that's right you go shut your
frakkin face oh oh oh
another friend in the party room okay
which way am I going yeah but I got an
electrical cord again didn't even know
if I needed it just happened you gonna
punch me
you're gonna slap me you know what you
should slap me because I just I want all
this to end okay see ya see ya man I
keep expecting them to slimy but they
know slap how can they not slap I'm so
slappable at this moment but again it's
like is that a moral dilemma is it like
like what kind of existence is that what
existence is that is that any way to
live is that a life worth living I say
no if I was trapped in a tree for all
eternity slave to another's will
well what was the point then I hear
something guys there did you hear
something
I think I heard something I think I
heard something
hey there was something over there I
heard oh I hear skitters campers and
then I heard baby voices something tells
me that the babies aren't gonna be too
happy about my current course of actions
I don't know what happened over here
horrible demon babies in the darkness
horrible dark darkness demon babies all
right I can I can attest that is awful
and I hate it and I don't want anything
to do with it and if they come over here
I'll put a bunch of in their little baby
faces i markiplier I'm not afraid to
punch a baby in the face in the means of
survival in fact I burnt one alive nor
daddy my probably dead I burnt it it was
a tree I burnt a tree that's all I want
to say about that
so don't mess with me is the lesson that
I'm teaching you right now because if
you mess with me I will let you on fire
that is a lesson to be learned here this
is awful
why do I have to go down here I don't
like this can the babies stop whining Oh
little [ __ ] babies down okay yeah I'm
going right back up I don't want to go
down there I hate that I hate everything
about that that is the worst thing I
don't want to be here this oh god I hate
this I hate this so much
oh I hate this so much no no no no no no
none of this I hate this so much guys
you don't understand how much me I hate
this I hate it so much I hate it so much
oh my god I've never been this scared in
a long time I hate it so much I hate
this oh I hate this No
please I want to live that way why now
oh hey this a fine blind dear oh god I
hate it I hate it I hate it so much I
hate it so much
Oh Kylie's demon babies no it's a
clearly a trap I'm a big strong brave
boy but in the face of demon babies I'm
not okay I'm not okay
don't stop I mean stop don't don't stop
being you cute you little piece of [ __ ]
okay you little you little Scrabble a
babbling baby you're gonna get the full
face of fists if you know what I'm
talking about if you keep messing with
me all right I will mess you up I will I
will fight a baby I will 100% fight a
baby I will I will slap a baby oh I saw
baby I saw a baby I saw that baby I see
you baby
no I'm not okay with that baby okay all
right do not like do or not I do not
like I'm gonna go this way
cuz it's secret way around the baby or
it's gonna run right smack into the face
of the baby
am I gonna run smack into the face of
the baby I'm gonna run smack into the
face of the baby okay now that I've seen
the baby I think I'm relatively okay
with the baby the baby is okay the
baby's everywhere everywhere babies oh
no why there's so many babies oh well
there's so many babies I hit these
babies okay all right so there's a baby
right there and there's a baby making a
loop I think I'm gonna wait till it goes
by cuz it's blind Ryan's blind can't see
me can only hear me guys you know you
know I understand I just don't like
babies apparently I mean babies are fine
in all I guess
where are the babies okay all right
okay so the baby can walk right by me
and that'd be fine I just gotta hide
between behind medium box bigglesworth
yeah okay all right well you think the
tiny box Tim would be here to help me in
this and uh no no no no no no no no I
hate that tiny box step where are you Oh
God
no and don't like it No
oh that's the worst thing I've ever seen
in my life oh that's the worst thing oh
that's the worst thing oh god don't you
don't stop oh no oh oh no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no I'm falling down
I'm falling down let me fall Oh scratch
my eyes out okay well god damn it I
tried to fall down I don't like these
babies where am i where am i oh wait
what wait wait where am I
wait what no no why no oh why where am I
and why am i here I thought I was dead
I thought I would have just been a fun
game over and I could I get to try again
you know that's usually how it works
it's like it's like the forest when you
get dragged down into the cannibal pile
okay there's no way out of here is there
ah I am just gonna be stuck here until
they come and eat me that's all I have
to look forward to yep okay I am doomed
I am doomed
oh wait what's that wait where are you
uh what's in front of me
hello hi I see you three oh hello
you don't look so good okay all right
well that's strange
okay wait and there's nothing here okay
what about can I get over here yes this
is bizarre why is this here what is
happening I don't get it I just don't
get it I don't understand you I don't
understand anything that's happening
here okay all right
well see ya see ya see ya
see ya okay all right all right okay all
right
why am I here again why why am I here
weird how did it continue it I don't get
it
the fate of the unforgivable the Norns
wasn't always so generous some humans
were punished for their rotten souls in
the form of purgatory and had to suffer
through their worst nightmare over and
over again until the Norns was satisfied
break it break it break it break would
break what break what what do I break
I'll break anything
I broke a family apart with fire and
gasoline I'll break anything don't like
it mommy is sick
ah mommy got bitten oh no wait no no no
the punish they can hear you I know that
I know all about that I know about that
oh man I'm not looking so good my arm is
a little messed up okay what do we have
here
okay now I'm gonna stop being a little a
little [ __ ] baby I must start punching
little [ __ ] babies in their punchable
faces okay everything's good
okay now I'm dead now they hear you
don't run okay all right that's I should
have known that I knew that my panicked
instinct told me to run and then I ran
so I just ran I couldn't help it I ran
that's all I did that's all I wanted to
do yeah Oh No well I can't see [ __ ] oh
that's awful
I hate that okay well I'm gonna light a
match I suppose I can't see where I'm
going
okay that's that's the worst thing
that's a bunch of SpongeBob
impersonators over there ah it's like
going to the world's worst spongebob
convention boy okay I realize like for
this entire episode my face has been
permanently stuck oh I hate this okay
fern Elise buck like this okay all right
righty-ho then let's see you crawling
again I guess
okay I think I'm home free I'm not gonna
oh no nope nope when I said I was home
free I meant the opposite of that cuz
there's many of you oh there's so many
of you okay well there's a problem was
this like planned was this plan there
didn't seem to be a way to get out of
there oh boy oh boy oh boy well I'm
gonna be quiet oh that's awful Oh what
happened to the children in Sweden is
this what all Swedish children look like
before they grow up you can just grow up
like this gremlins lurking in the caves
they lurk in the caves for a few years
until they mature and then they come out
and they're like Oh Hubert II hid and I
am fine now
okay I just gotta make it through this
area they definitely didn't hear that
man this would be a bad time to discover
that my game is listening to my
microphone and listening to me shouting
rant and rave like a lunatic in any
other circumstance screaming at the top
of my lungs
is a good deterrent for evil but now in
this one moment I need to be quiet as a
mouse do I do
what do I do you just keep going oh my
god oh my god oh my god please keep
going oh oh oh no oh no who walks around
I'm a dead man who walks around I'm
alive apparently okay all right I'm a
live man who also who out no one heard
that no one heard that
how are there so many babies how many
babies did this town have how many
babies how many babies how productive
were these people Oh
haven't they heard out of a goddamn
condom in this town okay
all right oh that's where it went oh
good I've been waiting to play my harp
to you I've been hoping and praying upon
a star I wonder if I could have made
this without getting caught like the
initial time I wonder if that was even
an option or but if I like absolutely
had to be caught no matter what okay
well either way they're gonna hear this
so is this troublesome can you look at
the goddamn music sheep
[Music]
okay well I got that but my blood seems
to be fully uh
treed
okay well
okay well they're pissed off at some did
I do that I did the others me those oh
that was all me 100% Oh didn't hear a
thing
stealth is the night okay all right man
my pinky finger sure is getting tired of
hitting this Crouch button kinda know
where they are
Sam I hear I'm Sam I like it oh don't
like that no paint it nothing behave
where are they
it seemed right this don't feel right
something ain't right about this [ __ ]
right by me it sounds like it's right by
me sounds like it's right behind me okay
it's fine it's fine I think it's fine I
think it's fine I'm not a hundred
percent sure about anything at this time
but I think it's fine
he's just designed to make me think
they're all right by me not gonna run
though no need to run why would I run
runnings for losers okay
okay
okay
just gonna calmly walk ignore that just
gonna calmly walk calmly walking calmly
walking calm walking calmly walking I'm
running now I'm gonna run down
I am extremely running now runnin runnin
runnin runnin runnin runnin runnin this
a good thing I love running there's
something by me should I look behind me
I really want to look behind me huh oh I
want to look behind me oh no oh no oh no
there's a lot of bones
how are there's this many people in this
town it doesn't even make sense I can't
play this in time oh I'm dead I'm dead
I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead hey you wanna
you want to listen to a tune you listen
to a jaunty tune okay I'll play you a
jaunty tune
[Music]
okay kids this is uh this is what I call
Wonderwall hope you liked it wonder how
this walls gonna go away huh well watch
this these are some big bones those are
big bones
those are some big bones alright well
then I'll see you around kids see their
kids have a good one Hopa Hopa well
that's a lot of medication wait a minute
that's a lot of medication that's a lot
of medication wait hang on there's a lot
of medication and needles
[Music]
was this all just a figment of my
imagination he did not shout at me to
jump
[Applause]
[Music]
getting really loud in here let's get in
quite loud maybe you could not do that
is there any other way besides jumping
[Applause]
all right thank you I guess uh why is it
so goopy
what the hell happened oh hi oh good how
about no how about no how about no how
about no how about they took the heat
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
so I should turn around and run is what
you're saying I should turn around and
run funny about all this alright well
wonderful ah thank you for that mmm
great skin treatments team what happened
where am i complete the circle son he
can't see
[Music]
- okay see ya
I didn't have a choice I didn't do
nothing
Oh God Oh stuck in an endless loop of
torture that's awful
is horrible ah man ah that's so cool
that's so cool but I wonder if there was
a way to break loose of the cycle
somewhere in the game like if you found
all the secret pieces or if you found
some secret thing in the game I wondered
I have no idea if there was another way
because they didn't give me any choice
at the end there but maybe there was
like another like avenue that you could
have taken like if I had gotten all the
way down there without being captured by
those little things maybe then I would
have found something that would have
been a little bit better but then I just
wasn't good enough I guess so I'll leave
it up to you guys if you guys know of a
different way to go through it or you
want to find out for yourself I'll put a
link to the game in the description
below and just thank you everybody so
much for watching let me know what you
thought down the comments below and as
always I will see you in the next video
[Music]